[Music]
son
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to the
podcast hear me this book with Steve
Rannazzisi I'm the host thanks for
joining me again hope you had a great
week mine was really good started off I
had my younger son had a birthday this
week which was amazing at an emotional
week I saw that right after write to the
podcast last week I saw that video of
that 7 week old kid hearing for the
first time oh my god it destroyed me I
cried I mean I don't know if you've seen
this video and I don't even know how old
it is it just got passed around this
past week I think the 7 week old kid
named Lachlan I think would happen on
Australia and yeah it's just it's tear
gas I mean he's like upset and they're
putting it the ear hearing aid into his
ear and then all of a sudden he just
hears his parents voice and he smiles
and it was just like I but uncocked yeah
I don't know what that says about me I
mean I'm not having a rough week it just
it was like one of those things that hit
me he was like my roof you know it was
beautiful to watch but yeah my son
turned five this week so it was sort of
an emotional time yeah my youngest is
five now we have no like babies anymore
they get like kids now that's it
yeah was awesome we had a little thing
on Tuesday for his birthday and then a
party on on Sunday which was lovely
because look here's the deal
it never really rains after January
February in in LA so rarely do we get
rain in May and of course it was
supposed to rain on Sunday was an
outdoor party and my wife was you know
flipping out all week but my mother's
credit and I'll say this my mother tells
my wife to put rosary beads now my mom's
a devout Catholic so
you know this is yet a we gotta chalk it
up to that but she tells my mom my mom
tells my wife put rosary beads on the
front bushes outside and it will not
rain so now look this is what she also
said she goes if it's a hundred percent
chance of rain it's not going to work
but if it's like 50/50 it's always going
to work and I'm telling you right now
we woke up on Sunday it didn't look
great party was from noon to three it
was cold but no rain kids showed up had
a great time we had a couple Power
Rangers show up those guys killed it
entertaining the kids running around the
park and then a 2:30 boom the skies open
up pizzas done everyone's happy birthday
and everyone ran to their cars it was
perfect perfect perfect perfect so is a
lovely lovely time uh and you know it's
nice to see the kids have fun and you
know presents and all that stuff now I
have a million things to put together
and it had to buy a ton of batteries but
it's worth it it's better than going to
the Met Ball
I assume sure some of you out there some
of you went to the Met Ball right you
guys are Met Ball people did you I don't
even I mean I see the pictures and stuff
because you know you're in entertainment
so you did all my feeds and social media
stuff had it in it but I just I get it
it's a charity event it just it doesn't
look like a fun time it looks like I
mean men wear tuxes and that's fine and
you know I can always just rock a tux
I'm not that uncomfortable in it but
like they'll work at some of these
outfits it's I mean I don't even know I
don't know if you saw what Katy Perry
was wearing but it was like I think it'd
have advertising on I don't know what it
was I don't know what the theme was it
just looks like so much work and not fun
to do um but my wife is always like it's
like huge for her did you see what did
you see much she want no I didn't see I
mean yeah I don't understand it I'm like
a you know I'm sort of like a
like look I like look hot like it would
be nice to look hot like some people
looked hot
I guess kendall jenner looked hot she
wore like a really that's like hot but I
don't know whatever like some people
were in costumes so yeah I guess that's
it I'll never be invited to the met Met
Gala sorry sorry babe you'll never get
to wear a potato sack if that's the
theme that year you know another one off
the list the Met Gala never be invited
to that uh Yankee still look good this
week was a good sports week for me
swept the Cubs what a game Sunday night
was God I turned it off it was like four
to one the ninth inning you got your
clothes are coming in
bing-bang-boom next do you know 18
innings later they pulled it out swept
the Cubs Rangers are just I don't I mean
that overtime game on Saturday overtime
games just destroyed me so cautiously
optimistic hopefully they can pull it
out this week by the time you hear this
you'll know whether or not it's happened
yeah oh you know what by the way I
wanted to I wanted to talk about this
show that I'm watching now the path my
wife and I rented to show the path it's
on Hulu it's with Aaron Paul you know
I'm Jesse Pinkman from from Breaking Bad
really good show I am all in on joining
a cult I'm pretty sure that I'm I'm
built for cult life free free
smoking pot not an issue at all they've
worked that in see that's the thing with
creating your own religion brand new
it's like you can just kind of work in
stuff that you kind of are cool with
that very loosey-goosey unlike you know
there's really not a lot of rules and
stuff so this cult life thing it's it's
a good show if you check it out on Hulu
it's really I mean twisted good
interesting like you know it could be
the Mafia it's all the same sort of
stories but it's interesting the way
they tell this one Aaron Paul kills it
Michele minor hand monahan I'm not sure
how you say it but so good everyone in
Hue dance he's in it he's British but
you wouldn't even know it he's just
great cult leader creepy weird dude so
I'm into that and then I'm gonna start a
book pretty soon I'd be getting some
suggestions who sent me an email I
wanted yeah this email was great I got a
great email am I gonna say the person's
name um it was um
it's I mean people are psyched about
like they want different books now which
is cool but yeah I have to start I have
to start a new book pretty soon and I'm
going to take suggestions and so yeah if
you have any book suggestions feel free
to email them to me at hear me this book
at gmail.com I'm getting a ton of great
ones you know people are complaining a
little bit about oh well you know you're
not talking about the book all the time
it's not it's not a book report no one's
gonna pass a test based on this podcast
it's an interesting jumping-off point
for a conversation sometimes we'll get
into the book if I have questions about
it or you know interested in like the
path of how it goes but or the narrative
but sometimes it's just you know sort of
a you know would just use it this week
was a great example of that this mate
this week's guest is Rick Ingram who is
a dear friend of mine
a great comedian I've known Rick for
probably about 13 years now he we've
gone on the road many times together and
when we when I asked me did the podcast
he's like yeah you know I'm not an avid
reader but I read a ton of Hunter s
Thompson books in my 20s so I just found
that interesting that you would just
kind of read that specific author and
you know in the twice we get into that
we talk Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
but this is not the drug-fueled
telling drug stories version of what
people might want that book to be so we
talked a lot about Rick and i's
relationship and what he's gone through
with his health we and we get into you
know we get into the book we get into
Hunter s town
a little bit but it's not something that
we're going to break down you know fear
and loathing
scene-by-scene or you know page by page
from the book so if you're expecting
that that's not what it is but it's very
interesting conversation because Rick
first of all is one of he said he is a
throwback to Rickles and he's an insult
comic he's a crowd war comic he works
the crowd he talks to people he's very
quick he doesn't think he doesn't have a
big filter which is great I love that
about him
and so he his his insight and too in
first of all his health I mean we would
get into that but he's got type one
diabetes and found it out later in life
which was crazy so we talk about that
and to me it's interesting because the
way he's dealt with it and things he's
had to endure I mean he's um he's just
he's a hard worker he really is he's
kind its overcome a lot and he's I'm you
know it's crazy I've he was a door guy
20 years old when I met over 21 years
old and now he's uh you know it's got a
wife and kids so it's not um but yeah we
do Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas and
like I said it's not going to be a
breakdown of it but we touch it we move
it around with our with our thoughts and
yeah it's it's um it was a great
conversation I love this guy and I think
that you guys will enjoy it this is Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas with my man
Rick Ingram
[Music]
no I can't
Jack yeah yeah
it never ends bouncing around from one
thing to another
but yeah next year it's just one school
one pick up one drop off bing-bang-boom
will be nice much better phones off yeah
so that's what it is we picked two
school and then we drew a circle and
then we came up with this place
schoolers Jia's are pretty solid I'm
guessing a lot a lot of Asians maybe
yeah the the past Pasadena area has a
decent amount Cal Tech's here a lot of
smart people the Cal Tech's right by
it's right down there so they're all
over the place hanging out Starbucks and
everything we were we were all those
kids looking at school stuff when we
started looking at where we wanted to go
and we're racist so basically like has
to be majority white kids mm-hmm and
it's pretty limited just a few sections
of Los Angeles most of them cost a lot
of money yeah I mean there's no question
that there's definitely a premium tariff
paid for Caucasian neighbors yeah but
this this area seemed like it there is a
little bit of Hispanic people but it
seemed like it was mostly white people
and Asian people
mm-hmm you got to have money I guess so
a little bit yeah it's a little bit of
money but it's cool and you know the
kids are they like it here so but and
then now you have a daughter which is
crazy I mean you're we're at my house
doing the podcast and right now forth by
the way I don't know if you've ever had
service like this and in their podcast
what babysitting though very rarely do
they have take care of usually usually I
just have the lever in the car wherever
the podcast is crack that window based
on temp yeah you just you make sure you
have two keys leave the AC on low you
don't want to you know just drain your
AC up no the baby doesn't need that much
cooler plus freons expensive very
expensive and I don't know how to do
that so then I
how to find a guy you need a freon guy
you need another guy freon guy so tired
of finding the freon robot and then the
guy that fixes the ya robot so you just
check on you lock those doors yep I mean
I'll leave one unlocked you got to leave
one unlocked in case you don't want to
you know if there is a kidnapper
very rarely they don't check every door
yeah that's no way to they check all
four door people looking they're going
to be I and people around to to now they
don't I mean unless they want that baby
if they do say unless they want that
baby I went through the trunk I mean you
are leaving a baby in there yeah you
have a baby man congratulations like
wonderful news I was very excited for
you and your wife yeah I think I don't
remember who it was I don't even want it
so imposed to line up last night of from
2004 whoo hot year not a lineup but it's
an employee lineup okay we were all on
it yeah crazy I I mean those were good
times those were great times yeah I mean
I can't you know I left college early
and I didn't really make any friends I
was pretty just a very angry individual
mm-hmm so that was kind of my that was
really my glory years of 2004 I would
have been there's more a lot of people's
glory or yeah that's true it's really no
other place in the world by the way were
tired Pramod East or ya carefree time
Rick got to the Comedy Store fairly
early in his life compared to most
people you know like 20 21 yeah I just
wait basically I waited till I could get
into the club at the end of to LA and
then and then he promptly came to the
most deranged place yeah in Los Angeles
and then we got him a job and you know
suppose you specifically you and Eleanor
got me a job yeah well we you could tell
you the jobs at The Comedy Store all
that all the people that work there are
comedians but then again it's you want
to work with people you're spending a
lot of time that are good decent people
and out of the the crop of new peanut
mayor out there very rare you are a side
traffic a good sense of humor yeah you
were good to be around fun to be around
and you can go with it yeah
and I mean I would say out of the crew I
was with Danish no Neil were part of
that group so they were good guys
obviously but other than them it was it
was pretty slim pickins yeah there's a
lot of like 45 to 55 year old homeless
drifters and that crew you know Mickey's
Jana Daly Laurie listen think chicken
yes those are the guys I was picking
numbers against just being like god I
hope I get well because it also had
helped to have you as I used to host
those years so that you you would have
to host an actual show so you would have
you know write four or five of those you
know people like you know these are
crazy people who are you know actually
homeless or living some sort of assisted
living places and then help they come
here because you know it has a bit of
Fame on Sunday nights they can get on
stage do three minutes that's it and so
you know you'd have three or four of
those crazy people and then like our
Rick would come up who is like sensible
and made sense and had jokes and stuff
and then you know and then it would be
way back - so you had monitors the
audience were there was no audience but
whatever people there you had to keep
them there when you have six it's
important you don't walk any of them
yeah and that was I mean that was
basically every week it was you'd be
lucky if you had ten people like that
would be the best week in months usually
it was like four to eight people by the
end of the open mic there might be ten
but I remember he was like you go up the
back stairs and if you saw a whole row
of people you're like oh my god I'll
hold the whole row is filled dream yeah
and then but thank God for you because
it was like an ally then you would you'd
be able to call so you got you had self
awareness of the situation you were into
so you would write fun of those guys as
well yeah I took some of the heavy
lifting off of us yeah I mean you
basically had to address it especially
if you're hosting to me the point of the
host is you're basically speaking for
the audience there's a few of us who are
really good at it but there's a lot of
people who are terrible at it and it's
like if you don't know how to make it
like we're all part of the joke yeah
then it's just you just seem like an
[__] who's hosting a show filled with
terrible homeless people there has to be
some level of self-awareness that you're
all saying we can
just go up there and plow through this
like this is a real professional show
yeah when you know you have essentially
a man named crispy chicken on stage yeah
what the the most swollen testicle of
all time
yep Woodridge show it if the drop of a
hat so this could be one of his closer
so then you can't just go or you're like
what an act huh ladies and gentlemen
godo keep it show me a little on you
know it's like they're gonna leave ya
over yeah doomsday is what most of those
open mics were yeah but they were good
times man we we we went on road trips
together that I mean I'm just talkin
like trying to think back of like the
amount of memories that we have together
are gettable road trips the polish or
stuff so the fact that I just you know
to just of those that I'm turning 40
this year so I always haven't liked
spending this time thinking about like
the last 10 or 15 years and to now that
you sitting in my house and you know
suburbia with our kids
yeah is a pretty it's a big difference
from where we started yeah okay that's
that's for sure I couldn't imagine that
this is where my life would have gotten
to mm-hmm ten years ago I mean I guess
that's probably what everyone says it
did it tip of you like right now if you
could have been like I'll go back we'll
go back seven years and you can cash out
you get the [__] out of town I mean
[Laughter]
there's a lot to think about that you're
like well um I'm uh I'm a stay-at-home
dad
I mean cashing out and can I get to pick
where I go or is it just like well okay
yeah you can probably pick where you go
I'm gonna go back to Kansas I I would
never do that no I won't even go back
and perform like people are like oh I'm
doing Stanford Suns are you going
anytime soon like I have been in nine
years yeah last time I perform there
last time I was supposed to perform
there they basically I flew back in I
supposed to feature and then they flew
back on a Wednesday doing shows Thursday
Friday Saturday and he called me in
third
stairs like I got bad news man I'm like
what's going on yeah can have you do
shows in basically Chris Porter who is a
friend of ours yeah dude I started with
was in town and he wanted him to do the
spots but instead of just being like
yeah he can do the show and you guys
lead to do this
he just opted that I was off the show
really I was like well I'm already back
in in town yeah well yeah I mean there
ain't much I can do this weekend you
sticking around for next weekend no no
not that's why I booked this weekend
typically it means when I be here yeah
so I was like [__] that I haven't been
back since
do you like don't you don't ever go home
spective as a family and stuff I see
your family out here a lot though yeah
but not a lot but I mean I didn't think
about four or five times in the last 10
years yeah yeah my family comes out once
at least once or twice a year different
members some large family so but uh I go
back like maybe once a year in recent
years I had grandparents dying so I had
to make multiple trips that was
definitely breaking records for days
home mmm oh my oh my best friends from
back there I'll live out here now so
funny line she's all those guys so it's
did I hope Kansas City crew yeah I just
got about the not only yeah were you 4
Horsemen of Kansas City I mean but you
were sort of the catalyst that got them
out here right yeah I moved out here I
didn't know anybody I like yeah I had a
couple friends I went to one one
semester of film school in Santa Fe New
Mexico and I made some friends and they
were more intent on kind of doing the
film's school thing so I knew a couple
of them had lived out here and slept on
one of their couches for like a month
and then that guy Dave's girl moved out
here at the same time and she basically
was like I'm going to move back to her
where I'm from unless you get rid of
these guys oh really so then I hope they
made him yeah I basically just took
Dave's roommate and we got a place in
Manhattan Beach and then and then my
paedon know either of waitering at what
is that
island Islands yeah I was at Chili's and
torrents man little Billy's in torrents
probably the worst experience of my life
that was the first time I ever
experienced racism towards me towards
you
yeah the chat always dished out braces
yeah this boilers that hold on wait a
minute wait hold on I'm I'm I'm the
minority hey all right
yeah I spent I probably call you
it was always white boy yeah there's a
lot of white boy white boy seems to be
I'm fine with white boy yeah I was okay
with it most the time it was it would
wear on you depending on how they do it
or like what they were saying torrent so
so people know is like the Beverly Hills
of ghettos it's like it's really to
Magic Johnson's isn't that in Torrance
to the Magic Johnson's the movie
theaters there sometimes yeah it sounds
right where around there yeah yeah it's
like just just east of like the Redondo
Beach area so there's like parts of it
that are okay but then it's also it it
blends and fades into Long Beach so you
get that LBC crew coming in expecting
that sizzling service they need
strawberry lemonade refilled every
second now so it was it was just how
many fountains likes lots that they have
dedicated the strawberry lemonade like
you had three large yeah even at all
times
they never had like any other there was
strawberry lemonade they have like a
sprite yeah your coke products and then
enormous vats of strawberry lemonade and
just endless like the I work two
restaurants in Kansas before I moved out
here so it's kind of a I was used I
worked at a barbecue restaurant so we
have very white-trash clientele I was
used to white trash people and then I
moved out here and I worked at Islands
and Manhattan Beach which is like
upscale you know money for loves islands
there's one here in past Pasadena yeah
how she loved it it yeah it's basically
just a fancy burger play exactly and not
even that fancy just more expensive than
it should be fancy it makes you feel
like for a second you look around you
like can I be in Hawaii now and I'm on a
strip mall but you know what yeah sure
tell it enough for me
good with it oh yeah I had about seven
of those sweet Hawaiian shirts mm-hmm
put one on just feel your soul dying
time to go give blue our burgers to
people that was the big sellers
pineapple teriyaki and you were just
doing spots at night then right coming
up yeah after that the new spot and I
actually got I got fired from Islands
like maybe two months after I started
working at the Comedy Store because they
needed me to do more shifts and I was
like I'm not available at night I pretty
much worked at the common idea or six
seven nights a week
he did everything yeah they'd let me do
anything except for phones I wasn't
allowed to do phones because of the
racism there man yes they said they felt
I had a the wrong attitude yeah it's
fine on the stage yeah but you know
talking to customers and stuff sometimes
it comes across it always shocked me
like they'd let like by lack and guys
like that yeah I mean the phones just
start berating tea but I was like I
don't LAN well look again we go back to
the pool that you had to choose from
true you had to basically choose your
own mint like what mental disorder do we
think will work best with photos its own
ships and answering you know talking to
the people everyone's got to talk to the
people but at some point you know over
the phone you spent the entire 20s there
yeah yeah right if I were working there
I was 21 and uh they're probably
guessing I got fired probably mid 20s I
got fired by Paulie on the road with
Paulie because I didn't get a door shift
covered you were actually you were
supposed to go with him oh really like
Charlotte or Columbia South Carolina or
something smart move by name and you
booked a commercial I think bingo and so
I got a call on Wednesday as I did we're
going dick the Carolina bro style which
one yeah just got the big one so she's
all right and I got my Thursday and
Saturday shifts covered but no one would
cover my Friday it's like whatever I'm
going with the boss's son yeah I'm good
yeah
and then Dean the manager commented
while we are at dinner I guess he and
Polly's been talking and
so I dinner Polly was like oh by the way
dude didn't get your shift covered last
night michael--ah yeah I'm here
yeah I'm doing you a favor I did you got
it you got it
do your responsibilities like what oh
boy until then yeah lost my my gig my
dream gig working for 25 bucks a night
for 9 10 hour shifts
if I hadn't stolen my fair share of
booze no way I was worth it no it was I
mean look we were there we got to hang
out we got away with a lot of stuff it
wasn't exactly like yeah you get away
with more there than you did with
Islands I'm sure sure but I mean it was
you yeah I shifted or shift at the end
of your career there isn't exactly you
know you don't you know you don't care
about I team fired me over the phone Wow
he was just like I just gotten a pilot
and I was like I was waiting kind of see
if it was gonna get picked up or not
right and you know cuz if it didn't I
was like I still need this job he's like
no bro you got a pilot you're one of the
guys people look at now you got to go
nothing all right okay you gotta go
gotta go man you know not the courage to
actually very naively yeah just kind of
like you know though anyway bro you're
so I guess I'm you by your names like
well you know it's not it's not saying
bro you're winning this it's just like
you know so good so you're quitting me
who's quitting who where are you going
to be in ten years I'm still gonna be
there when I asked you to do the podcast
you I asked what kind of book you really
like I haven't what Karen what you said
but something that I haven't read
anything but yeah parenting books and
diabetes-related oh of course yeah
you're you tell me your 20s you found
out I found out I was diabetic on my
30th birthday yeah on the day I spent
the entire thirties 20 I see you in a
lot of pain I remember our trip to
Alaska oh yeah and we thought you got
food poisoning on the way home yep
because we ate a Quiznos yeah yeah I was
and then you buy was pretty much I've
never seen a stewardess let anyone land
while they played well the bat some ones
are the bats and land the plane like
she saw how sick you were yeah she was
like sir it's okay I won't tell anyone
I'll risk my entire career yeah she put
it all on the line and she would knock
on the door I I mean I spent probably
four and a half hours straight in that
one bathroom on the plane I never
returned to my seat to just knock on the
door every couple minutes
hand me a little cup of ginger ale I
would take excuse it was so terrible and
it was like an overnight one so I was
like red eyed yeah I was asleep and I
just turned I remember turning around
seeing you and I'm you were like green I
could shaded like a horrible shade of
green yeah it was brutal and we all
thought you just had food poisoning or
something yeah yeah I mean it happened
to me it would have but that was a
particularly bad incident and what
happened to me a couple times a year but
I was just always kind of sick it was
just a very miserable person because I
felt horrible all the time it started
when I was probably like 24 and then got
progressively worse as I got towards 30
and it's just my my pancreas just
basically shutting down and no doctors
being able to figure out what's wrong
with me because I was terrible stomach
issues or something or a sort of I spent
thousands of dollars going to GI doctors
to have a good news night had thousands
of dollars to burn and it's a wealthy
and you're mr. flows great I just kept
racking up credit card debt and be like
that I'm gonna get a show soon so I pay
it off then and just kept going further
and further into debt but it was you
know when you're in your 20s you think
you're invincible so I was like I'll
just get through it and after a couple
years I was like I'll just be dead by
the time I'm 35 for sure look the rate
I'm at yeah
and uh you know doctors most of them
don't know what the [__] they're doing a
lot of them have a specialty and if it's
anything outside of that specific thing
they're just going to give you a generic
answer at what point did you start to go
this B died like that when did people
start to put it together
you're talking like years of going to
the hospital or a doctor I'm still not
feeling great is
like are you on to the point where like
I when I eat this this and this or is it
because I drink or like what is it what
is making like at what point did they
start to go you know what maybe we
should just because you know that is
that a check of your blood
yeah you just pretty much you prick your
finger and take like a literally a drop
of blood is all the tape no one ever did
that test was basically I've type 1
which is juvenile diabetes technically
so I was too old to have that and I was
too skinny to have type 2 so just never
occurred to anyone I never saw an
endocrinologist who would have been like
let's check your blood that's like a
diabetes endocrinologist yeah it's a
diabetic and entirely doctor really they
do it they deal with anything that
basically has to do with like metabolic
rates and all that stuff so I got I have
a endocrinologist I see multiple times a
year now saying a guy who basically
saved my life in the hospital but no one
ever tested it it just didn't occur to
anyone I guess so they just kept giving
me different pills and nexium and nexium
yeah prilosec like they just gave the
basically thought I had I was diagnosed
multiple times with severe acid reflux
and one doctor told me I had intestinal
migraines oh my god drop draw it sounds
like so much like you know it's like
migraines are tough in the head so if we
put a minute come yeah that's how I like
it basically I did like yeah probably
yeah I did an endoscopy so they would
get her they knock you out and then they
scope down your throat oh your God so
they do this and luckily my parents dick
or do they do with a tube it's probably
just I go pro on the head
I'm guessing just get that big big guy
out here go for the long dick you don't
want to complicate no no no no it's got
to be skinny and
yeah my parents helped me out who is
like 12 grand and the guy was like yeah
so you have a herniated esophagus which
means the stomach acid had just burned
the whole the bottom of your esophagus
has a like a basically a door that goes
to your stomach and it lets things in
but it makes it so things don't push out
except for under extreme distress or
whatever so mine is just burn completely
gone and then he's like yeah you got
severe acid reflux obviously and erosion
of yeah declining prilosec and although
again and when he said um just after
looking at all the symptoms I think you
pretty strong candidate for intestinal
migraines I was just like whoa and I
went home on my cat that sounds no dumb
and then I googled it and then it pops
up and like the very first thing that
pops up is like it's disputed whether
this even exists oh my gosh [__] does
he now know we can google this stuff now
you got to you got to make sure you know
whether or not I can find out you're
full of [__] immediately so that was the
time I was like what I will never trust
a Greek person there it is so I I
thought I had acid reflux but then I
realized I was drinking wine like right
before I went to bed in my hotel like
kind of like sitting up in the bed right
and it just you know but it just
repeated on me ah yeah but I was like oh
I need all I need give me all that all
anything that cures whatever's happening
in here all the pills but then some guy
walks in he goes did anyone test his
[__] blood and see if he's got I mean
to me when you hear what were your
parents like when they heard like
diabetes I mean obviously it's like oh
[__] okay to deal with but like how it
almost like I remember we all won all
the comedian's Hariri like we saw white
like diabetes like first get a like for
like you know a lot of us don't know
which one's going to kill people so
you're like oh [__] yes no no no it's
just a livable thing but like something
that like probably should have even our
dumb minds realized that it should have
been caught way before that yeah and
part of the problem was because it was a
since I got such a late case of type
on they don't really know what causes it
but essentially I have an autoimmune
disease version so my my body just
started attacking my pancreas perfect so
slowly over my early to mid 20s my body
was basically just destroying itself and
I didn't have any of like the sure signs
of diabetes until the last three or four
months like the when they got really bad
was when you took me to La Jolla and
remember I had to stop oh yeah so like
that was a big drinking weekend too was
the last time I ever got drunk we were
on the beach getting [__] so we went
down there and Steve picks me up and we
drive down it's like the time of day we
left carpooling it should take like
three hours yep but I we got [__] and
we or something you had to stop for me
so I could pee twice you're like my god
you have a bladder like my grandma I
just need to pull over man oh yeah bye
we're going to La Joya Comedy Store
there's a club down San Diego so it's
like a two-hour drive it'd be you know
for if someone has a quarter yeah and so
yeah all that stuff started about three
months before I found out I started
drinking gallons of water a day like I
just couldn't quench my thirst I had to
pee all the time I couldn't sleep for
more than like 40 minutes without having
to wake up and pee and you know it's a
combination then if I'm drinking so much
water but even if I drank one cup of
water I still had to pee all the time
and I what would you pee out though and
be like three drops piss and then just
like the feeling like I needed to go
until all that is like that's at that
when you're at that point your pancreas
doesn't work at all and so what had
happened was leading up to that my
pancreas just didn't work well enough so
all the stomach problems were
ketoacidosis which is something that
happens when your blood sugar is too
high for too long your body starts
producing ketones and it more or less
you have to pee all the time because
there's so many ketones in your blood it
irritates your whole urinary tract and
everything like that so
oh my god I started losing weight and
basically from the time we went to La
Jolla at the time I was hospitalized I
lost about 40 pounds
I went from yeah and 155 you really
weren't someone who had a lot to give to
begin with yeah I was down to like 115
when I went into the house and your
watch six one I'm just about six foot
yeah yeah so it was it was I was like
Manute Bol skinny or it's just like this
doesn't seem right and Boone shocked the
final straw for me on my 30th birthday I
was having a beer at the Comedy Store
and are they this is the night before so
at midnight I turn 30 I'm celebrating
then I was feeling terrible in general
but he see a friend of ours and I drove
down the comedy store we smoked a joint
and I was going to have a beer and do
whatever was I'm 30 and Boone shock
walks up and he's like you look like you
got AIDS oh by the way boom Shakalaka is
a open mic immediate economy store is
about 55 trans transvestite yeah
crossdresser drifter drifter mobile a
thrift store
yep with Amazon the first Amazon before
I heard of Amazon look or something
I asked one time he would have all these
random books you got books let me let me
show you book me and you show you all
these books together you stolen from
someone and then I'd like none of these
books are good and you'd be like what
kind of book you like and I'd be like ah
I wanted to read Howard Stern's private
parts okay so he goes up I know how
aster in private parts so two weeks
later I'm getting money out of an ATM at
the Comedy Store on Sunset two weeks
later out of a bush boom pops up right
I found that book and the cans we
powered turned at a hard copy heart
oh I sum through it there's no like
pages missing anything I know alright
yeah
gimme two dollars like alright I give
him five dollars for the book yeah thank
you that was the first my first the
period into us yeah yeah he told you he
and this is he told you yeah I look like
I have eight I mean this guy could he
could be the poster child to like
mid-80s AIDS yeah he looks like he might
leave patients oh you're losing the
battle yeah say I used to tent use a
terrible just going on and on a my god
and then people kept saying cuz I'd lost
so much weight like Manny look you're
really skinny
what's telling like yeah it got so bad
that Pete had to start yelling at people
like he knows he's skinny leave him
alone and then then that night I got
real sick same type of things when I was
in coming home from Alaska like I just
couldn't stop throwing up and so I went
to I'd set up an appointment at the sag
clinic and I had to be one on Beverly
the 1i wanna wear the family with
burbank we have burbank and uh so Bob
Hope yep that one and it was uh it was
interesting I got I had to be like three
weeks was the earliest appointment they
had for me so I went and met with a
doctor and he explained what my symptoms
were huh and he pricked my finger and
took my blood and then he was like hmm
well I'd like to maybe do some more
blood tests like maybe do a fasting
blood test can you not eat for 12 hours
then come back we'll do we'll do another
like a blood test all right whatever
and then I never all hours yeah that's
what you need you need a 12 hour fasting
blood levels and I never made it okay
what did you probably passed out before
that right I was I would take showers
basically like hot showers so how I try
and get my stomache myself we get so bad
would spasm and you can actually watch
it special and so I I got in a bathtub
at night and I basically didn't get out
until the morning at like 5:00 or 6:00
in the morning I was so weak like
couldn't even get out of the bathtub and
Korean came in was like what are you
doing I was like I just don't feel good
then she was like we we need to go the
hospital I'm like no I got a blood test
and three hours and she was like
[__] get out of the bathtub I'm like
I don't they
can when she helped me out like
literally had to pull me out of a
bathtub and then Oh God took me down to
the your wife now by the way you had a
marry a person that has to lift a man
out of a bathtub yep
and that's like your Liberace exact look
hottie
get me my tub tubs done so then I made
her take me to the SAG Clinic first and
the guy was just like we're not saying
[__] out of here man
I don't want to be responsible yeah I'm
wet naked body looks like a slightly
younger mr. burns just this frail oh and
what's the hospital they immediately sag
had sent over the information that they
did not provide me from the sag clinic
the lady was like okay so you're
diabetic you're in diabetic shock so
Michael what do you mean and she's like
yeah your blood tests showed that you
have diabetes I was like they didn't
tell me that and she was like oh well he
probably should have told you that and
then now they hooked me up to IVs and I
couldn't lift my arms and legs at that
point I stayed in the ICU for several
days while they struggled to get my
blood sugar down so when I went into the
SAC clinic he pricked my finger and took
my blood test when I was like Hulu
interesting I'd like to maybe get
another test when he probably should
have just been like you need to go to
the emergency room right now right now
my blood sugar was like 560 and it
should never be above 140 so I was like
five times the level the maximum level
and he was like ah interesting
maybe we should do a fasting blood yeah
so [__] so yeah so well I mean did you
feel I know you were you a little bit
relieved though you're like alright well
at least we know what what this is I
mean I was and I say I didn't understand
that all the stomach things were a part
of it so in my mind when they start
telling me I'm like literally like maybe
I should just give myself all this
morphine and do myself and now I'm gonna
be diabetic
and have stomach problems and it wasn't
like the fifth day in the hospital that
when the doctor came to talk to me again
my endocrinologist and telling like yeah
so what should I expect they said
they're going to probably release me
tomorrow and and he was like well you
know just you got to eat a good diet
it's got to be consistent you give
yourself shot with every meal a
different shot at night I said what do I
do because I have stomach problems I
throw up a lot how do I work it out so
that if I eat when I'm supposed to and
give myself a shot and then I throw up
is that going to cause my blood series i
we shouldn't throw up like Linnell i've
got this problem and he's like you know
you're not going to have that problem
anymore I was like what do you mean he's
like we you have ketoacidosis I'm like
what are you talking about he's like
yeah that's all part of it he's like
that's why I don't understand how no one
figured this out I was like all they
would had to do is just prick your
finger every doctor's office has that
capability I was like oh cool but I
thought they'd do that in school like a
nurse's office it's like yeah a kid
doesn't feel well maybe they check his
blood sugar I mean my dad has type 2
right you know the other one yeah and
and so yeah he's constantly you know
checking his blood sugar and stuff but I
mean the unbelievable amount of time you
spent just sitting there going I wonder
if it's tears or even just being like
forget it this is the way it is and yeah
we'll just ride this [__] train till
the end
yeah Matt then we give it a pamphlet and
that was it yeah and then you just like
well now I have to kind of learn about
what this is and that was about me
basically he gave me like the crash
course and the hospital through your
insurance like they have these different
thing like you go to support groups and
you meet with like a nutritionist enough
and they kind of fill you in on
everything
people who recently found that they have
diabetes support groups yes that what it
is like it was and I went only went once
I'm not doing this [__] again but I went
and it's all people with type 2 and then
me and so it's just like a bunch of
adults most of the
are overweight a few of them are just
like old sometimes old people [__] that
stops working and but everything at it
was basically set up for people with
type 2 or my so then you need to eat you
know more vegetables this is the
proportions that you should have of
different things and if you want pasta
you know you can still have it try and
limit yourself to six spaghetti noodles
you're like what spaghetti noodles no
thanks yeah I'm alright so I just
thought that I was like another buck
does this apply to me and they'd be like
it does not like what am I doing here
yeah you probably had a how did your
diet change I basically just had to
start eating healthy and counting carbs
something that that's really the main
thing if you don't drink anymore right
haven't hadn't had a beer since that
night I I used to eat like a comic I
chicken fingers and pizza and yeah now I
eat a lot of vegetables and I prepare
all my meals for myself basically I
rarely eat out and I just have to know
how much I'm eating because I have to
give myself a shot - how many times a
day I do one shot for every meal and
then a shot of a different kind of
insulin at night uh-huh before you go at
least four sometimes five depending on
if I get the amounts wrong or whatever
god I just even it out um did you was
there a book in particular that kind of
helped you along with that or no or it's
just a ton of research and stuff yeah
it's all just basically like I just
started buying books online about
diabetes and like looking into it just
so I can understand it better and you
know I wanted to believe that there was
like I'd be able to figure out this is
why I have it but there's no scientific
proof for what is it even nf1 its
genetic but like there's there's
identical twins where one of them has it
and one of them doesn't and they don't
know why they think that could be like a
virus that basically exists dormant
inside your body people get it and if
you happen to have the right genetic
markers and that it turns into diabetes
I bet ik and if you don't get it then
you'll never get it and you're lucky and
god damn man so but yeah I don't know
well only history of it so is one of the
things where it's like I don't know it
explains a lot
number one explains why you came to the
Comedy Store because you knew the path
that you needed to go on to get to
healthy you know that's probably the if
you were in the quarry with all of us
you never would have found out that good
exactly right
damn your limit you told me that you
read a lot of Hunter Thompson books yeah
20s yeah I got I got really into it I
had a college professor I showed up to
an American Studies class completely
hammered one who's like probably one in
the afternoon on a Wednesday or
something and my professor immediately
called me out he says man someone in
this class he probably smelled pot on me
or something but he's like someone in
this class is awfully skunky laughs the
best I'm like oh man it's so funny then
he was like once tell us about your
morning so far Richard I'm like oh [__]
it's me
so that after cut is like I want to talk
to you after class I'm like [__] and let
he was just asked me like what are you
drunk and high when I'm like oh really I
had two shots but I'm not really drunk
but I'm really really high he is like oh
man that's the best
oh if they ask me you know Reid Hunter
Thompson stuff I said no not really I
mean I knew he was that the Johnny Depp
mm-hmm fear and loathing movie was had
come out or whatever I knew people who
loved it because they were drug addicts
and he was like oh you should read it I
was like oh yeah check it out he was
like you're never going to go to a
bookstore I'm going to bring you a copy
like all right so he brought me a copy
of Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas and I
read it and like a night just sat there
and right I was like Dan
were you a reader before like did you
read or you like into reading like I
don't know how I've never read anything
in a night I read a lot like when I was
in high school for fun or just like [__]
that you had to read for school I've
basically never read the
it was supposed to read for school I
just would cheat my way for anything
like that but I was very when I was in a
like a teenager I was fascinated by
biographies so I read a lot of a lot of
biographies mostly like actors or
athletes like I basically read every
biography there is to read about a
baseball player
bo Jackson probably yep Oh Hank Haren
has a great biography Willie Mays has a
great biography so I've read that all
the time but I never really got into
like fiction so it always just seemed
dumped
yeah I'm it's amazing to me I only read
what I was had to read and that was it
like I never had anything that fun so
you I mean so you could plow through a
book then and not ya know probably an
amazing I would have to really be into
it for it to keep me going like that
like I think that's why I loved reading
about like baseball players cuz I love
baseball so like I never got to see Hank
Aaron or Willie Mays these guys play
because I was born in 1981 but I'd hear
like my dad or my grandpa talk about
these guys and I was like oh cool
and so like reading about it you just
like it fascinated me and those guys
they lived in such a weird time as black
guys playing pro sports or they'd have
to travel to places in the south and
stuff and you're just like you're
basically getting a history lesson on
top of the fact that you're like reading
about out of the region yeah yeah ball
player so like when I back of the bus
boy yeah we decide to go it's not before
a home game Jesus yeah God like a team
played in they play games in the south
the black players which there'd be like
one or two on a team would have to stay
in a different hotel in a different part
of town than the rest of the team and
then the old stuff like there's a lot of
ball players from the south in the 50s
and they didn't care for civil rights so
it was just like it was like Adam Jones
talking about ya know I handled at
Fenway now only reticle the entire
stadium yes like yelling Adam
and you know Willie Mays is incredible
and he would just hit the [__] out of
the ball and track everything down and
then fight he said by the end of the
game I'd be like you just hear like one
and word out of the corner yeah Oh God
but I mean well by the way that probably
fueled you to become the insult comedian
slightly exactly yeah racially
insensitive
I said hey comedian if they could do it
in the south
I just gotta [__] out today get well so
willing people at the Comedy Store at
night yeah yeah but Isaac but didn't a
hundred Thompson book fear and loathing
you just plowed through through it and
it was one of those things or it's the
his writing style I just kind of spoke
to me where I was at in my life then cuz
like I was straightedge all through high
school I never had a beer until I was in
college and then I very quickly got into
the party scene my first week in college
I was at the college of Santa Fe and I
saw people shooting heroin and I was
like what the [__] yeah and I was
drinking beers like two days later just
like well I'm not doing that but my god
I gotta do something
I gotta start drinking these beers
before they start putting me over my arm
yeah fun yeah
so I started I could just kind of got
into that not those were the people I
became friends with for the people who
had weed and start smoking a lot of pot
and just kind of experimenting with
different things mushrooms and stuff
like that so I started reading it and
his voice was just it was literally
nothing I had ever read before I haven't
read any I mean some of the Rolling
Stones articles I read but nothing I've
never read any of those Hunter Thompson
books oh yeah from what I gather it was
it all over the place is it's sort of a
DD esque yeah it's very very nonlinear
and you know it's his his phrase has
gone to journalism because there's
there's aspects of reality in it but
it's just so far into the psyche and off
the the charts of reality that as you
read it you just you don't even know
sometimes grounded in a like a maybe in
a place
or an event that you like all right I'm
familiar with that I'm familiar with
this but like the things that this guy's
doing or you know stories that he's
telling I have no frame of reference for
that what he's doing yeah and it's out
of control like Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas started out as him writing an
article for Sports Illustrated and then
he was going to do an article about a
Chicano protester that got killed by
police in LA in the early 70s when
they're protesting the Vietnam War so he
wanted to do a story about that and the
social injustice of it and he got
connected with a lawyer
who's one of the side characters in the
YA book and like in the movies played by
Benicio del Toro and so he they weren't
comfortable being a white guy and a
latino guy meeting in LA to discuss this
stuff so they decided they're going to
go to Vegas and both of them just got
wasted all the time and so they went to
Vegas and then he they were there for a
weekend just getting smashed and doing
stuff and then he had to go back for
like a month later for Rolling Stone and
they want them to cover just basically
like a police convention or like
district attorneys were meeting up and
discussing how to deal with
counterculture end up writing the
articles or the things that he goes to
the assignments I mean are they well uh
the Sports Illustrated one it was like
described as his his article was
viciously rejected okay like there yeah
we can't print this but the Rolling
Stone took their part of it and they
were just like it was awesome given the
hour so they ended up releasing it as
like three articles and then from that
he turned it all I like tried to focus
it more basically turned it into a novel
and it's just it goes it really does go
all over the place but there are aspects
of both of those weekend's combining the
one story
basically and so he's like trying to
prove the stuff but he just can't stay
on the track so it's like a long winded
just commentary on like the
counterculture of the 1960s and how he
sees it failing and how his taking
everything to the furthest extreme in
terms of intoxication how he's doing it
for the right reasons because it's a
yeah you know he's not like Timothy
Leary where he thinks he's improving his
mind he's doing the opposite yeah he's
good to see how far he can yeah it's
good and go as far into depravity as
possible that's what their actual
purpose is and but I was always someone
who felt like I missed I missed out on
the good years like how great would have
been to be alive in the 60s and was he
like that its whole life I mean I don't
know if you know hundred but I mean like
was he sort of us he might I mean I
don't know but like maybe he was a
straight-laced person who just was like
[__] it I'm taking the wheels off yeah I
mean I he was raised he's from Kentucky
from like Louisville so I think it was
raised in a fairly strict environment
and kind of wanted to get away from it
which is something else I guess I could
relate to growing up in Kansas yes like
I was surrounded by conservatives and
I'm like I don't think these people are
right for me I wasn't religious and you
know looked down upon where I grew up
like heavily like you can't be an
atheist you might as well just sacrifice
goats and worship Satan if you yeah I
love Jesus
I said no choice so I think you know he
started get away from that one of his
other books that I really like to which
has also been turned into a Johnny Depp
movies called the Rome Diaries and it's
one of the first things he ever wrote
and it didn't get published until years
after his other works had already been
kind of published cuz I think he finally
kind of put the thoughts together but it
was about his time as a young journalist
he was in his early 20s and he basically
lied on his resume to get a job working
at a newspaper and I think it's Puerto
Rico and like the late 50s uh-huh just
like the craziness well he's got him
though right they started yeah
until I could and a lot of his novels
like that one he you know he changes his
character's name to whatever it is and
that way he doesn't have to follow the
reality of it he can alter parts of it
but it's a you know he just basically
wanted to go somewhere where no one knew
him and he could just get hammered into
oblivion every day and because it was he
famous I mean I can't really remember if
he was like he wasn't like on talk shows
nightly it wouldn't be like a thing
where when again it was probably this
you know the seventies and stuff so it's
like it wasn't a thing where he could go
to a local bar and not have people come
to him and yeah author him or like he
could just be anonymous yeah he was
totally anonymous then by by the late
70s he was pretty well-known because so
many of his articles had been published
in stuff flowing stone and he was
basically I probably thought it was cool
by then the party with him yeah I could
get a chance and he seemed he was
already unhinged in terms of like you
just like dude this guy's crazy like the
stories of his life told by the people
that like interacted with him regularly
you just like dude this guy's a maniac
how do you interact like he had a lady
that was basically as maid and then I
could help him out as he got older and
one of the things 100 Thompson is he
loved weapons love guns perfect and uh
it's like he had he lived in Aspen and
he had multiple instances where cops
showed up because he had blown up such a
large amount of gunpowder that it could
be heard in the Aspen Valley and he was
like an Oscar to town people like there
was a huge explosion never hurt anyone
or himself just like blowing [__] up
just not blown up yeah but as I got
older you know his brain started to kind
of unhinged from years of excess
basically but he was in his room
basically talking to himself and his his
maid lady walked by and was like heard
him talking and so she knocked on the
door to see if he was all right and it
just took some buckshot through the door
and you felt bad and like you open the
door and she's like you showed me he's a
lot of the Oscar Pistorius her yeah yeah
but I thought there was a bear she why
would there be a bear inside your cabin
well you were scratching at the door
amazing
I wasn't scratching like he just told
that story like there so this happened
he took he doesn't on I think there's a
clip of him on Conan from like the early
2000s where he talked about how damn
eight years ago I accidentally shot my
maid he's like oh my god how'd that
happened I think tells me it's like wait
to you you accidentally shot her because
you thought I was a bear in your cabin
hmm seemed reasonable at the time you
don't get away with that anymore not
even if you're an Olympic athlete yeah
yeah now they frown on and the lady
lived luckily so alright in you'd
working for a different thing then but
well then yeah let bygones be bygones
like I look
why did you read so many what do you
reread this book over and over or like
did you go back I mean seems like here
and loathing or not yeah the Hunter
Thompson books like the only Cup like
there's I mean there's probably like 15
of them maybe yeah that's probably about
right that's about how many I've read
and you just went on like a rotation
just yeah I decided a lot of them are
harder to find so I would you know I if
I was somewhere I'd look in a book store
and you sometimes he'd find a random one
once you get start ordering [__] online
pretty easily I started doing that but
his uh depressed I mean I was always
kind of depressed going through my 20s
that helped it really better to make you
feel like well no it just kind of gave
me a it gave me an escape I guess and
like I liked to party and I like
experimenting with stuff but I never
could take things to the battle I did
yeah so that was kind of interesting to
me just to to read or to hear that stuff
are you reading anymore I don't read a
lot now I mean now I got a suggestion if
you get a chance yeah you're talking
about biography normal Donald's book
which I mean I haven't read that many
biographies I like Norm's book is
basically it's sort of I mean I think
people have sort of said it's sort of a
Hunter Thompson s where he's telling
stories about his past right on a drive
to Vegas with Adam eBay okay and that
sort of his side and but the stories are
all narrative but they're all wrong he
tells him the way he wants all right so
it's like almost like he reverses it
where it's like he walks in to Dick
Ebersol whoever he's like what running
NBC news like and the guy was like look
we want you we need you to tell more OJ
jokes and he's like I'll tell you
something right now I will not disgrace
that man's name he's been acquitted by a
jury of his peers I would like you know
just reverses exactly what happened but
it's a fun sort of quick thing like
Hitler and his sense of humor I think
you know I love that my god
so yeah I'll talk I've got a lot of
local like people that we know
references as well so if someone says
it's all over Adam that's um I mean he's
like on every page every day I called
him he gulped like a dunce like a talks
down to so much like I knew what the
plan that was going to happen but I had
to take time out of my day to explain it
to this dummy that is Adams think you
know like the comedy the dumb comedy
store manager
but yeah so if you get it up chef nom
that I got I'll give you a copy of it um
thanks for coming on the pocket and I
play sure you um telling a do you read
but you have to still stay up on on
diabetes and like yeah and stuff like
that or I don't really know right diet
like hey man yeah a celebrity like to
Jai Kali write a book like it gets
easier something like that he did it his
book would just be like do anyone got a
job through footballs and the Jets are
like we're not even integrated harnass
not a lot of books I mean I've read lots
of them so there's not a lot of books
that come out now it's like new
information but I subscribe to a bunch
of like diabetic journals and I get
emails with like the latest
endocrinologists you know advances
things like yeah though constantly
buying stuff out there's there's all
sorts of things that are kind of being
tested right now that could be great you
know the work
on artificial pancreas is and oh really
so you can get implanted so I wouldn't
have to do shots and it sounds like you
know we're five or ten years away from
basically being able to live a life
without having to check my blood sugar
and we'll see if it all happens or what
side effects of it are but heavier can
you get your daughter tested she
wouldn't show signs for another I think
would be like another four or five
months before okay she would show signs
of it but she basically has like oh
we're just gonna let her guess
four-letter barrier out yeah
just whatever you know let her figure it
out man do what I did you know by the
way she's my wife is watching it right
now you're responsible if my wife gets
pregnant which I did it would be
impossible for a vasectomy but she you
know this is a lot of time with a baby
and they're having fun I could hear him
out yeah it hasn't been any crying yeah
so the aunt she's a girl you know we're
done Tracy's surrounded by boys so yeah
it's yes I hope this isn't a catalyst
greater more on a weird like going on a
date tonight so be plenty of time to
talk about it sorry buddy place Radley
on me later
[Music]
that was my good buddy Rick Ingram and
we talked about Hunter s Thompson and
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas I hope
you enjoyed it that was this week's
episode please do me a favor give rick
Ingram a follow at Rick Ingram on
Instagram and on Twitter and also if you
want to email this podcast it's here me
this book at gmail.com my website is
Steve rent is easy dot-com and I'm on
twitter and instagram @ c rent is easy
just start spelling it and then google
or whatever you're on does the rest
again o dates I'm going to be doing
stand-up may 19th and 20th in La Jolla
at the Comedy Store one of my favorite
places to hang out perform at be around
chill I've been doing that place for 17
years now
and it's a blast so you had a lawyer
Comedy Store may 19th and 20th and then
June 8th 9th and 10th let me make sure
that's correct
June dot 678 sorry June 6th 7th and 8th
comics at Mohegan Sun in Connecticut
I'll be on the East Coast June 6th 7th
and 8th and then I'll be there for a
little bit the summer so yeah come check
me out at comics in Mohegan Sun Jews 6 7
8 there's a tickets link on my website
and that's it guys I will talk to you
next week
be well
[Music]
me
here
Oh
you